the 21st century the u.s
marriage rates hesitate i know in the uk
but i use the u.s one the u.s marriage
rate has declined from more than eight
marriages per 1000 down to six marriages
per 1000 population in 2019 the marriage
rate is the lowest level since the u.s
government began keeping marriage
records for the country in 1867.
why aren't people getting married
anymore
because
women don't know what men want in
marriage and the standard for men has
been the same
and so
women also don't really know their
nature either so
they kind of
they expect a lot from men when
realistically it's not really possible
given the state of like the economy
because in the past in the 1950s and and
before that
like it was it was okay to be
hypergamous in a way because women
didn't really have much money so if a
guy makes uh i don't i don't know like
by those standards 30k a year that was
fine because they were they were still
living with their parents but now like
women actually out earn men and many in
in certain industries i'm not sure but i
know that they go to college more than
than men do and so they want a man
that's more educated they want a man
that makes more money and like
realistically given their nature that
makes sense due to history but it
doesn't make sense now because
men and women are competing
and their standards aren't lowering
what do you think
um
we're sorry my mind went somewhere else
can you repeat the question yeah why um
so marriage rates are lower than they've
ever been why aren't people getting
married anymore
um
i'll say society now high expectations
um
i would say social media also like um
back in the day kind of a thing where
there's a lot of cheating nowadays
people are easily swayed both men and
women and i'll say social media plays a
big part now like instagram and stuff
like that
and
also now a lot of people know
that what i would say kind of him they
won't settle for just you beating me up
and stuff like that whereas back in the
day a lot of people would that they'll
compromise and stay but i know i'll say
some um a lot of people know their value
yeah and more work
kind of thing you think people know
their value
yeah sometimes yeah i agree i think
that's i think when not not the value
part i i agree i think the reason why
men and women aren't getting married
anymore is because of logism yeah yeah i
think it's work yeah okay go ahead i
think that's a big part of it and i also
i think it's a few things
people don't really know their roles and
they don't discuss that up front
so when it doesn't work out for them
either way for the for the lady or the
man
they they almost feel resentful and then
they they divorce and they think the
grass is going to be greener
i think the grass
grasses greener syndrome is legitimately
a thing it comes from like social media
and dating apps
and
people have never had to commit like
they have to commit now because they
have so many options now
so i think if you can commit now
it says a lot more than back in the day
because back in the day
you only really knew who was around you
in your town you know what i mean you
couldn't if you're a baddie you know you
could get flown out to somewhere that
stuff like that just didn't happen you
know so um for you because you've
actually um
seen dating change i'm sure over the
past like 20 30 years
why did more people get married before
and why don't they get married now
i think there was more stigma you
couldn't have kids outside of marriage
and it's for it to be okay i think
that's one thing
and i think there was a lot of pressure
from
families for you to do the right thing
nowadays you can cohabitate for years
you can have children
in that in that partnership and not
really have stability although you might
think it's stability
you might have been with the same person
for 10 years
but i think um
i don't see that as stability really
because a lot of people leave
relationships they go into another one
they create another family so i think
values have changed what people see as
the norm now has changed cohabitating is
the norm and
even people that i know say
they would never think about marriage
they'd think about living with someone
but not marriage as the ultimate
commitment but my parents married that's
what i would look
and look to do because i think it's the
right thing for me
um even though you know i'm at the age
that i am i still think
it's it's the right thing to do
do you think marriage do a marriage is a
bad deal for men nowadays now that we
offer less than ever as women
so the average age of first marriage in
the uk is 31 so we don't have youth
anymore um purity like i think most men
would pray for a girl with less than
five bodies nowadays
where they used to get virgins um and on
top of that the divorce laws are very
heavily favored towards women where we
can leave and take half and there's you
know
sayings like it's cheaper to keep her um
on top of that if we leave we can also
take the kids and put them on child
support
um would you say that if
that marriage is a bad deal for men
today why would they get married i said
depending on who you're marrying it'll
be a bad deal
okay i think by and large you're
you're spot on with a lot of those
points i think one of the biggest ones
is just the
the divorce
because a lot of things have been
equalized for better for worse
why has that not
reflected those things and the divorce
laws yeah yeah because if they were
and i i'm speaking from someone who i
actually want to get married you know
and i think if you're a guy
and you want to get married maybe a
prenup might be a good idea if you're if
you are of some high amount of value
but i think it's an even bigger
sacrifice for a guy to make now than
ever before but because of that reason
like you could be in a relationship the
goal
earns as much as you or more
and then
you divorce and they get even more right
so it's i think that is
i think one of the biggest factors what
would you say
um so one why do you still want to get
married even with all of that
and two what would you say um would you
say a prenup is the solution or are
there other solutions that you could
think of from a guy's point of view so
i'd say prenup is part of the solution
and i'd also say that
um i like the idea of making a sacrifice
i think a lot of the best things in life
come with sacrifices
and
also my mum and dad had me quite late in
life so they're kind of
everyone i went to school with their
parents were younger so they're an older
generation and i guess
maybe i'm a hopeless romantic you know
the the comment section can rinse me for
it i don't i don't care but
i do yeah yeah they will yeah i'm sure
they i'm sure they will but
i think
i'm confident in myself enough to still
flex you know like brendan fraser if you
know the actor he had one of the worst
divorces ever i don't know all the
details
but he's just come out with some amazing
movie right he's still flexing because
he knows he's still got it
and i think that shows confidence as a
man that if you can still make that
sacrifice
and you can still earn after
you know do you think another solution
is just living together and never
getting married potentially yeah yeah i
think
i think kids in my opinion is the
ultimate commitment and then marriage
after that because you'll essentially
make you're passing your genes on with
someone else you're choosing to mix your
genes with someone but
yeah i think cohabitation is
you know what's also a crazy thing is
that um
men i don't think women really
appreciate how much of a sacrifice it is
for men to get married
um because one in four marriages are
sexless
um so it's like men go through all of
this stuff to get married and girls
won't even say that sex is you do but
rare like girls won't even admit that
sex is a duty like they don't even get
sex whenever they want yeah i think
again
i think a lot of people again i'm not
saying i'm perfect but that's why i
think truth is so important because if
you go into something saying these are
our roles this is what i expect from you
what do you expect from me
and i will say okay i'll put a ring on
it
as long as these things are in place if
these things are not in place
no longer
then it's those are why i would divorce
okay
um what about you guys what incentive do
you think men have to get married today
i think culturally though i mean
our culture
we
we have we still governed under our own
choices
like i know africans and
some caribbeans africans more they
are gonna marry they're not gonna think
about doing prenups they're gonna get
married
even if they had children outside of the
marriage they're still going to get
married caribbeans i'm not sure really
if we're kind of into
getting married i don't know when was
the last time i went to a wedding but
like from an african point of view yes
they still get married
i just think that um
people are not traditional people are
untraditional and it's for the kids
right i think a lot of people in this
day and age think that
they forget that what is the function of
marriage
i believe it's for the children
you know it's both of you saying till
death do us part and if you actually
take the words you say seriously
which i don't think
i always i always think about that women
from the 1940s and 50s would like laugh
at us today because like they'd be like
oh you left because you weren't happy my
man had a whole family across town and i
stayed
you know what i mean like that used to
happen like families would meet at
funerals
and even um
you know i have some relatives that like
kind of you know stayed together through
cheating and like all this stuff but
like nowadays like girls will just leave
because they're not happy
which is which is crazy especially when
you have kids it's not about you it's so
crazy and that's why i don't think men
have any incentive anymore to get
married
like
because
initially men would marry for sex
because women want a commitment so and
women they wouldn't give sex unless
there was a commitment
and then they want someone that can cook
and clean and maintain a home that's
good with children and a lot of women
don't want children
um
and they they wanted purity like they
wanted a virgin and women aren't virgins
anymore and then at the divorce courts
on top of that
i mean and then and then as a society as
well like there's no shame with divorce
it almost seems like a life milestone at
this point it's really sad
and so now there's divorce parties yeah
yeah yeah
what there's women throw parties when
they get divorced oh my god this is just
yeah it's absolutely absurd i just like
as a like as a christian though i really
think like if there are
if there's like structures in place and
you're clear and and you
you i guess it's hard right because like
a woman can i don't know like
i don't know she could watch
like rollo to massey yeah and she can
like be singing his praises and saying
exactly what you want to hear get the
ring and then gain like 50 pounds and
sit on her behind and then take you for
half if you leave and like not give you
sex yeah that's what that's what women
do a lot of them
they get the this is like
i have men i had this guy he sent me
this long email and it was so sad it was
like um you know after watching your
content i think that was my wife's
second choice
because um after kids like i haven't
slept with her in two years
and he's like i make this much money i
go to the gym i do this i do this and i
don't want to cheat
but i i feel i feel trapped in this
marriage and if i leave she's probably
going to take a bunch of money but i
would say
and he also was like i love her but i
like this i can't but i would again
like going back to what i said before
there's certain conditions that i go in
on and i'm very hard and fast on those
conditions if they're not met then i'm
out
and if you take my money
all right
i'll get more
but i'm not saying that to be arrogant
like you got to the place you got to
right
and
again you i don't i actually agree with
a lot of you you're probably thinking
what are you saying mate because you're
saying there's no incentive but you
still want to do it yeah like call me
crazy but
in a way that kind of makes me want to
do it even more i'm a bit extreme that
way like i'll take on the challenge
let's go you know not if red flags like
i don't know for me if there's red flags
clear red flags why are you going to get
married yeah if a woman is not
connecting to a man i agree with you or
a man's not connecting to a woman right
why where is the motivation
to even think like i really want to i
see this as a long-term thing i agree
with you that's what i'm saying though
like as long as the criteria are met
from me and are still met like i would
say to him i i i would i always say to
like my friends i'm brutally honest with
them you know if they tell me like they
want to lose weight i just say like
move more eat less work out what you
need to do to to do that right and make
it easier for yourself
and i think it's the same i think
when it comes to relationships i think
it helps both men and women to take the
emotions out of it and think as
robotically as possible these are my
requirements if my requirements are not
met i am gone that is it
and i think another thing is
women would have a lot more respect for
their men if the man had principles and
stuck by them
so if they go in and say these are what
my expectations are right okay she takes
some of your money okay she takes the
kids you're gone right
she might actually have the most respect
she's had for you in years if you
actually leave
i think if that that guy that sent you
that email she might actually respect
him for the for the first time maybe
ever if he left no i agree i think women
take advantage of men that they know
that they can yeah definitely and um
yeah and that's the
that's the crazy thing is i i had a clip
um go go viral like a couple months ago
where i just said if your girl gains 100
pounds before she's even had kids like
you can leave you don't have to put up
with that as many of you know i was just
banned on tick tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible